hello everyone and welcome to another uh
most interesting game from round nine of
the tata still 2021 uh between anish
giri and maxime vashir lagrav
there was a lot of talk about this game
yesterday as it features
again none other than the night of
defense and as you as you might have
heard
giri made some 20 hour uh long course uh
with the video material
on the neighbor of defense uh so maxim
is the one that's usually the expert on
the night of but with
giri also being a great expert on on the
night off it's going to be very
interesting to see
how gary will try to break through or
will maxime finally be able to do
something with the neither because maxim
already lost two games to the night of
two
uh niels grandelus and fabiano carwana
and now he
will employ it again uh so let's see
what happens here
uh so gary with the white pieces as you
might imagine
goes for e4 uh we have c5 the sicilian
defense
knight to f3 d6 and now again we will
have the knight of setup captures
captures uh
knight to f6 knight to c3 and a6 uh here
again maxine goes for the knight of
defense
and every video we mentioned for those
who are new to chess that the most
popular
replies here are bishop e3 bishop g5
bishop e2 bishop c4
but pretty much any other move here uh
is possible
uh in the night of setup like we've seen
uh yesterday magnus played against the
grendelius queen to d3 which is uh
incredibly rare there are but a few few
top tier games
in the database and magnus was able to
get a win here but geary goes for h3
this is something that's called the
atoms attack
and it's uh it's a very aggressive
attempt to take down the knight of
preparing the the very early g for g5
but pretty much everyone
prepares the early g4 for g5 against the
night of uh so
what happens here we have e5 by maxim
chasing away the knight now you could
retreat the knight to e2 to f3 even b3
uh maxime decides to uh giri decides to
go back to f3
uh with bishop to e7 and now the media
the g4 as you have prepared it and
while you can uh try and prevent the g5
max team uh even invites it with castles
and this is
all all perfectly fine we with g5
chasing away that knight and now there
are two games in the database that
where knights the e8 was played but here
maxim goes knights to h5
and it's as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game
so let's see what happens here now geary
here goes for
bishop to c4 now uh as of course geary
is an extremely well prepared gentleman
and uh he probably has this analyzed
with
some really really strong engines but
bishop the c4
analyzed that for example at a depth of
30
doesn't really even show up so bishop to
c4 is
definitely a tricky move and it asks it
does maksim have anything prepared for
this because it's not
like in the top three engine suggestions
or maybe it is if you have like a super
powerful engine
so uh maximum replies with bishop to e6
he would very much like to trade those
bishops and
increase his presence in the center with
the pawns bishop back to b3
and now g6 now uh freeing up the the g7
square for the knight if you need to
shift it
and the just uh uh very strong blockade
in the position so here
bishop to e3 by giri and knight to d7
now
we have queen to d2 preparing the castle
queen side and rook the c8 so
very standard night of moves we have
castles here and here uh maxime goes for
knight to c5 and this is we're gonna get
back to this move because here
uh you either go uh you either go b5
preparing knight to b6 for example b5
you want to go to c6 and then you can
shift to the knight
either to c4 or if uh white doesn't
react you will have
additional support for maybe advancing
the pawn to d5 and so on
but here maxim goes for knight to c5 and
he allows the gear to immediately
eliminate that knight
and with the g f with this diagonal
being closed you don't really have much
much use of this bishop on e3
so this kind of even helps gary bishop
captures and see five
rook captures and now h4 is uh
supporting that pawn on g5 once more
also getting away the h3 pawn
from being a target uh to this bishop we
have knight to f4
and now uh the prophylactic king to b1
uh we have queen to a5 and maxim's
pieces are coming closer and closer to
giri's king
and now knight's the e1 this is a move
you always won't look for as we often
say the hardest move to find is with the
knight back
he wants to remaneuver the knight to d3
and then put pressure on the rook and
trade off this powerful knight because
this knight is extremely powerful this
night
on f3 is not doing anything so uh
that's usually uh a good advice when you
want to find a move in the position
look for your least active piece and
then try to make make use of that piece
so knight to e1
we have rook f the c8 doubling up on the
c file and now
knight to d3 we have knight captures on
the e3 king captures on the
queen captures on d3 and now comes a
vintage night of move uh
rook captures on c3 uh they say
if you don't uh sacrifice the exchange
on c3 in the night or
you know are you even playing the night
or no
no one actually says that but uh you you
know what i mean
everyone does this especially maxime he
always gives up this rook for night here
and it
gives uh uh for some very interesting
play so b
captures on c3 and now maxim doesn't
bother by
capturing right away he decides to
continue in great style and pushes d5
so here you open up this diagonal for
the bishop and also if pawn captures
then this bishop can come to f5
grabbing hold of this diagonal so it's
going to be an extremely sharp game
gary captures on d5 as now he has
created a pass pawn but he will have to
endure
some suffering for the moment bishop to
f5
queen to d2 and now bishop to d6 for the
moment
blocking the past pawn you do not want
to meet this uh and now
c4 giri cements that pawn on d5 and
offers a queen trade maxim of course
cannot afford to trade queens he
sacrificed material
so queen back to b6 uh and now
we have king to a1 getting away from
that b file a5 a4 was the plan so you
might as well get the king
to safety we have a5 and now c3
we have a4 as planned and now bishop
back to c2
and now even e4 sorry uh and now even uh
e4 and uh now this diagonal opened up
and uh it's gonna be it's gonna be very
interesting to see how gary defends
against this and he finds
a most uh devious move he plays bishop
captures on a4 and
in such a crazy position to to even
consider a pawn grab
is usually very dangerous but here it
works perfectly because
rook captures on c4 now bishop goes back
bishop to b3
chases the rook away and the rook to c5
now as the rook occupies the c file
bishop to e5 is coming
and maxine will of course try and put
pressure on the c3 pawn which is now
a very important defender to the king
here and now
gary finds an amazing defense rook h to
e1
he wants to blockade this pawn with the
rook and also help out with the defense
along the third rank because as long as
this pawn is here and this bishop does
not have a diagonal to use
that light square bishop will not be all
that impressive so here bishop to e5 as
planned
and now rook to e3 what's much better
than rook to c1 because this rook serves
a double purpose blocks
defends the pawn and also blocks the
very important e for pawn
so here queen to d6 maxime decides to
block the d6 the d5 pawn for the moment
because if you go for something
aggressive like
queen to a5 adding a third attacker here
for example rook to c1 and now b5 with
the idea of b4 taking advantage of this
diagonal then kink to b1 and now if b4
you can simply capture
and uh you've solved all of your
problems so rook captures king captures
and now queen a3 check king b1 and you
don't have a worry in the world you're
just gonna push your pawn to victory
like we said as long as this diagonal is
closed uh there is nothing for
whites to worry about unless you
blundermate or something like that
but okay after rookie three now we have
so sorry we have queen to d6 maxim again
has to waste a move to block this spawn
and now comes king to b2
and now not much left to do but continue
attacking b5 you of course prepare b4 so
gary prepares for that
and now rook to c8 with the idea of
maybe
putting some pressure on this a3 pawn so
giri defends it
preemptively so rook to a1 and now b4
uh this was only a matter of time
because this con before this
comes as this pin still exists with
eight captures on b4
queen captures making use of the pin and
now d6
and now a very sneaky idea because of
course if the bishop captures then the
queen can be captured
this pin no longer exists and if queen
captures then you just trade queens
and you are very happy you're up
material you rub the exchange so
you would have a very easy game so after
d6 we have rook to b8 now putting
pressure on the bishop here
and now rook to a3 very very interesting
defense by gary placing both of his
rooks on the third rank
and now just asking uh what do you what
do you do here
uh
i thought it was maybe the mailman i was
mistaking
uh but okay rook a3 defending and then
now comes queen
back to b7 interestingly if you try to
add a third attacker here with bishop to
e6 you meet
the very unpleasant d7 and now you
cannot go uh any peace grabbing because
after bishop captures d8 uh queen with
check and this is now terrible because
after king to g7
uh you don't have any discoveries
unfortunately because of queen to f6
check crazy stuff point is you want to
eliminate
the the pinning piece and now after
bishop captures or anything
this comes with check king captures you
just pick up the queen
and you are very happy so after rook to
a3
queen back to b7 not uh allowing the
queen to remain here now the bishop
can move can be traded and so on also
you keep an eye on the d7 square
and now king to c1 unpinning now the
bishop can move
sorry king to c1 not c2 queen to d7
again maxine has to blockade this past
pawn and now
queen to d5 so putting pressure on the
f7 pawn now the queen will have to
remain a defender here
uh we have bishop captures on d6
grabbing that pawn as the bishop was
also under attack and now
rook the a6 attacking the bishop twice
the bishop
uh well if you move the bishop then why
just trades queens
it's not a problem so here bishop rook
to d8
but now it's move 40 time control has
been reached but uh geary has a very
very uh
well uh sneaky move to grab hold of
the advantage uh feel free to pause the
video and find the the best idea for
gary while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding geary's
move and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's
rook capture rook captures on v6 just
giving up the exchange and going after
this uh
f7 pawn queen to d4 also also is a
possible move but the rook captures on
the
uh on d6 is much more forcing so queen
captures
we have queen captures on f7 king to h8
and queen to f6
check so uh very forced and giri says
here that he
has a winning end game as he does have a
past c pawn and he's just going to push
it up the board
so queen captures with g captures and
now rook to d6
going after the f6 pawn but now another
beautiful move by geary
f3 this is uh incredibly impressive
stuff because now of course uh you
you you cannot capture the pawn if you
capture it or rook the e8 is checkmate
the pawn covers
the g7 square so here maksim is forced
to go for something else we have rook
captures on f6
f capture sunny for gearing now with the
two past pawns
and now bishop to e6 offering a trade of
bishops first without wasting any time
gary advances the pawn further we have
e5 rook to f1 with check king to b2 and
now oh sorry king to b2 and now bishop
captures on b3 king captures and now
king the g7 maxim starts bringing the
king into the game and
giving out continues pushing his past
pawn rook to b1
check we have king to a4 and now king to
f7 the king now
has to improve his activity we have c5
of course you have to push the pass pawn
king e6 and now
even c6 and this is for those of you who
are new to chess a very important setup
uh
uh well sort of a relationship between
the king and the pawns when the pawns
are placed uh
like this with one one square uh in
between them
they create a wall and the white and the
the opponent's king cannot approach the
other pawn so now
you don't want to even if you could grab
this pawn most of the times
if it's a king and one end game you
cannot because this pawn will advance
and with
this setup upon creating a wall you
cannot uh
go go for either pawn so here rook the
c1 going after the c6 pawn
king b5 just defending that pawn rook to
c2 now comes
rook to e1 rook to c3 and now finally
king to b6 preparing to further advance
the pawn
rogue b3 we have king the a6 and now we
have a few
moves uh that repeat king b6 rugby three
check
king to a6 rook a3 check and now king to
b7
probably with the idea of reaching time
control as with king to b7 gear reached
moves as a 60
and now is granted additional time so he
can
he doesn't have to worry about time
anymore uh maybe that was the case i i
wasn't following the time at the moment
but
it does seem to be reasonable as uh
it's a winning position and you don't
want to mess up in time trouble
so rugby three check king to c8 and now
rook to b4
but there isn't much you can do c7 so
what do you do now
uh rook captures an h4 but even if you
don't capture there's not much for you
to do
we have rook to c1 uh getting the rook
behind the pass pawn
and now if you capture here just king
here let's say check
king here and next move you you get a
queen so
after this uh rook to c1 we rook to f4
but it doesn't help king to b7 we have
rook to f7 pinning
and now rook to e1 now gary defends this
pawn and is preparing king to b8 and
just queening the pawn and now all
that's left for maxine
is to try and maybe uh push those pawns
he does have two connected past pawns so
maybe he can give up the rook for
for the pawn and start pushing his own
pass pawn so king the b8 preparing to
queen the pawn
rook to f8 check c8 queen and now
captures on
c8 king captures on c8 and now h5 and
now maxim will
one uh you know one last attempt is to
try and make something of those past
pawns but now
king to c7 by geary with h4 king to c6
and it was in this position on move 70
that maksim bashir lagrav resigned the
game
and a a wonderful victory for anishigiri
who
crushed his own his own course basically
uh
and uh made maksim suffer yet another
loss
in playing the night of so this is
maxim's third loss in the night of in
this tournament and it's just
i don't think anyone got even a draw
playing the night off in this tournament
i could be wrong but there were no wins
with the night of so pretty pretty crazy
stuff
i guess everyone uh is extremely well
prepared uh
against the night of as you know there's
a lot of talk about the night of
these days so here for those of you who
are new to chess we're going to play
this out
even though it seems that these pawns
are very very aggressive
and fast it's actually not a problem
because for example h3
king c5 the white king even though very
far away he can actually catch those
pawns
g4 you're gonna go king to d for g3 king
the e4 now we're going to play g3 or h3
doesn't even matter white's next movie
is the same
so let's say h2 king to f3 and there is
no
queening the pawns because all of the
squares are covered and that's it
uh you're gonna have to play something
white will give up that you're gonna
pick up that pawn and now of course king
and rook against king completely winning
so very very interesting stuff after
king to c6 maxim resigns and now we are
going to see
the standings finally these are the
standings after round nine
as you can see the leaders anishigiri
fabiana
caruana and alireza ferrugia with six
out of nine
with five and a half pence andre and
jordan van forest
then with five magnus carlsen uh in
sixth place
with four and a half hare krishna
pentala and niels grandelius with three
and a half
young sister dududarado slavoitashek
aryanthari and david anton guihara
and maxime who is having a terrible
tournament uh with three out of nine
uh alongside dunching alexander with
three out of nine so maxime
is in grave danger of uh dropping out of
the the world top ten
if he doesn't uh you know uh really
improve in the
these last few rounds so we'll we'll see
what happens and alireza
maybe even breaks through uh into the
top ten so will this be the year that
geary finally wins the tata steel or or
will someone else be able to do it or
will magnus
be able now to maybe win all of the
games until the end
and you know just ruin everyone's plans
so a lot can still happen
uh we'll see what happens uh so that's
uh the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh
always play the night off it's a great
great opening uh i would like to thank
gerard cameron ansari
and joe erp for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the tata
steel uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day